and welcome back everybody so we see
criminals cover up evidence in many
Fashions cleaning supplies chemicals
even burying things in the dirt but one
woman in Florida apparently chose Diet
Mountain Dew so on July 1st someone
flagged down officers in Daytona Beach
to report a house fire after
firefighters put out the blaze they
found the body of 79 year old Michael
cerasoli on the floor now according to
the affidavit the victim had blunt force
trauma to the back of his head and
multiple stab wounds to his torso police
discovered a bloody knife near his body
and blood on the wall in his roommate's
room that roommate 35 year old Nicole
Max was arrested in the early hours of
July 2nd at a crystal fast food
restaurant she had blood on her leg and
her shirt which appeared torn police say
when they approached her she dropped a
knife and Hammer that she was carrying
Authority said that Max had inconsistent
accounts of what happened and requested
an attorney when asked about the fire
now here's where the Mountain Dew comes
in so when officers LED Max to a squad
car she was informed that DNA would be
collected from her in response Max asked
officers for a drink which happened to
be a Diet Mountain Dew and she proceeded
to douse herself with it investigators
claim that DNA from both parties was
still found on the knife at the crime
scene Max is jailed without bond on
charges of first-degree murder tampering
with evidence and resisting arrest with
violence so Brian maybe the fact that
it's uh Mountain Dew uh made her claim
that you know thinking DNA wouldn't be
on her I haven't heard that one before
so I think is the diet that washes it
off it's the diet yeah it's the diet
part no I I'm really confused because I
think is she trying to hide the blood by
mixing the Mountain Dew in because in my
mind if they're trying to get DNA from
her they want her DNA they already have
the blood and DNA just for people out
there who want to spread Mountain Dew on
them they don't get it from wiping your
skin cells it's from a buckle or bugle
swab from the inside of your mouth so I
don't know what she was thinking with
that but it hey it makes a great
argument for a competency hearing or
maybe an insanity defense because one
was ordered right there wasn't a
competency evaluation order do you think
that was necessary no there's nothing
you know mentally deficient with this
individual I don't know pouring Mountain
Dew on yourself you have seen where
Coca-Cola is you know corrosive and
they've you know shown evidence of when
it can destroy things look I think it
was faulty of her to think that the
Mountain Dew would cover anything up
because like Brian said obviously you're
going to get the DNA from a buckle swab
or from you know blood or something else
maybe to DNA but here I think what she
was doing was trying to cover up so she
knew she had committed a crime she knew
she was going to try to cover that up
and you know she maybe thought she could
rinse it off but I don't think there was
any evidence of the fact that she was in
any way mentally ill and you know to
order a competency hearing that's a lot
of exposure that's a lot of you know
money and it's a lot of time and effort
and I don't think they should have done
it here what do you you what do you
think I'm just surprised that Terry
didn't say consciousness of guilt that's
her favorite criminal one yeah this is
clearly you're trying to tamper with
evidence even if you are completely
wrong that's going to wipe it away that
would be I would argue consciousness of
guilt that you know there's something on
you that can tie you to this murder and
you're trying to wipe it away right and
when we you took the words right out of
my mouth right Consciousness because
when we talk about insanity if somebody
knows what they did is illegal and knows
that the police are after them that kind
of facts don't really help them that
much all right when we come
The Man Behind the oscar-winning film
The Blind Side now alleges in a court
filing that he was in fact blindsided by
his own family the controversy
surrounding Michael Oher's adoption
that's next
[Music]
and we're finishing Today's Show with a
story sending shock waves through the
Sports World in Hollywood retired NFL
player Michael Orr the subject behind
the oscar-winning film The Blind Side is
setting the record straight on his own
story with legal action a petition was
submitted Monday to a probate court in
Shelby County Tennessee and it alleges
that oars Guardians Sean and Leanne Tui
never actually adopted him when he was a
senior in high school he claims instead
they tricked him into signing
conservatorship paperwork they gave the
couple legal authority to make business
decisions in ore's name the filing also
alleges that the couple used their power
to strike a deal with the Blind Side
movie earning millions of dollars in
royalties for the Tui family but Aura
reportedly saw none of that money
despite the film being based on him in a
statement to TMZ sports the couple's
attorney said the conservatorship was
put in place to quote assist with Mr
Orr's needs ranging from getting him
health insurance and obtaining a
driver's license to helping with college
admissions and should Mr Orr wish to
terminate the conservatorship either now
or at any time in the future the two e's
will never oppose it in any way the
attorney also said that Orr received an
equal cut of anything made off of The
Blindside franchise and recently
attempted to Blackmail the twois for 15
million dollars the case has a lot of
moving parts so we spoke to an attorney
that helps athletes navigate the dangers
of Fame to get a little bit more context
usually the way to get a conservatorship
is with some allegation that this
individual whoever it is is incapable of
managing their finances so Michael Oher
is alleging in his petition I have
nothing wrong with me and I didn't I
don't appreciate the way I was depicted
in The Blind Side as being someone that
was not of full intelligence and he
feels that that harmed his NFL career
because people saw what they saw in the
movies and made assumptions about him so
you know it's to a certain point right
he's not alleging defamation or slander
or liable anything like that but he's
alleging that there was some element of
fraud that they had to allege to get
that conservatorship so that's really
your main difference you could be an
adopted member of someone's family and
you know as an 18 year old adopted
individual or you know even a minor
that's adopted have some control over
your finances it doesn't mean that
you've turned that over conservatorship
is quite the opposite once the
conservatorship's in place hey it's very
hard to control your finances but it's
very hard to get out of it so two very
different legal contracts generally
getting it out of the conservatorship is
stuff you have to show that you are of
sound mind and whatever that condition
that initially placed you in the
conservatorship has now passed um you
know I guess Michael Oher is saying that
I have nothing to recover from I have
nothing to prove since I was put under
this conservatorship under false
pretenses so that's really the debate
that's that's going to be fought here um
you know but certainly certainly we'll
see but um yeah that's what Michael Lord
wants to do at this point unwind the
conservatorship
and that's the part that I want to focus
on if he wants it ended and they want it
ended is this going to be quickly
resolved by the court well it should if
in fact they're saying that they will
end it because they know he wants it
ended I have to say Jesse I was a little
confused as to why a conservatorship if
there's nothing wrong with him why would
they want to have a conservatorship
where they're going to control all of
his decisions basically and they're
trying to say that they want to control
or help him get into college help him
with you know medical health insurance
he doesn't need to be in a
conservatorship for help if in fact
there's nothing wrong with him and if
they defrauded him if they made him
think look this is an adoption nothing's
wrong with you please sign these papers
I do think he has a good case but if
he's filed his petition and they have no
objection this should be resolved very
quickly is this a conservatorship issue
brand or contract issue because it seems
to me it becomes a question of did he
know what he was signing yeah it's I
think it's a contract issue that
believes in a conservatorship because
it's contracted to be a conservatorship
it would be what I think would be called
like fraud by inducement where you get
someone to go into a contract by making
a misrepresentation or a lie if he's
always under the belief that this is an
adoption where of an adoption it's just
like us with our parents so they don't
control my mom's Jamaican so she
controls my fun sometimes but parents
don't typically control our funds in the
way that if we make money as uh miners
or as even adults but in a
conservatorship you have that extra
layer of control and that's where he's
saying he doesn't want and I've been
trying to read this and go through it
before this but along with dismembering
or terminating this conservatorship he
also wants them to come to the table
answer some questions do some accounting
and see how much money they actually owe
him would he get money back for this
well he could and he's asking for
millions of dollars so in fact if he
shows that it was fraud and that he was
induced into getting into this
conservative ship because they lied
about anything and said it was an
adoption then I definitely think he can
get some money back it's getting so ugly
and I mean it's disappointing that was a
great movie and now looking like this
might be all a fraud Brian Terry great
to see you everyone out there thanks for
joining us here on Long crime daily
we're going to see you next time as we
discuss Justice in America
foreign